even if our ancestors consumed a full
spectrum of vitamins and minerals
every day mouths would very likely still
grow
too small what was true for our
ancestors was also true for us
because the problem had less to do with
what we were eating
than how we ate it chewing
it was the constant stress of chewing
that was lacking from our diets
not specifically vitamins a b c or d
95 of the industrialized diet
was soft our ancient ancestors chewed
for hours a day
every day because they chewed so much
their mouths their teeth
their throats and their faces grew to be
wide and strong and pronounced
this larger mouth with straighter teeth
allowed them to breathe more easily
food in industrialized societies was so
processed
that it hardly required any chewing at
all
here's some of the industrialized mush
that i grew up eating
yes of course i had extractions yes of
course i need braces and headgear and
everything else
here's the typical modern american diet
today
cheese sauces baked goods spaghetti
fried roots
it's all soft even what's considered
healthy foods
smoothies yogurt avocados
oatmeal it's all soft healthy chewing
starts in infancy the chewing and
sucking stress required for
breastfeeding
exercises the masseter and other facial
muscles
and stimulates more bone growth allowing
for that
upper palate to drop which leads to
wider airways
tell a few hundred years ago mothers
would breastfeed infants
up to two to four years sometimes even
longer
the more time infants spent chewing and
sucking
the more they'd increase their chances
of breathing better
later on in life with industrialization
came bottle feeding and baby formula
soon in many societies
infants were hardly breastfed at all now
dozens and dozens of studies in the past
two decades have supported this claim
they've shown lower incidence of snoring
and sleep apnea
in infants who were breastfed longer
versus those who were bottle-fed
this is why so many of the skulls that
i'd examined in the museum of
archaeology and anthropology
that i'd seen at the paris quarries this
is why
they had narrow faces and crooked teeth
it's one of the main reasons why
so many of us today are chronically
stuffed up
why our airways are clogged why we need
sprays and pills and surgery
just to get a fresh breath of air